avec cette carte les jeunes de 12 à 22
ans pourront bénéficier d'une réduction
de 25% sur le réseau européen d'air
france à partir du 1er avril prochain
c'est ce qu'a précisé ce matin monsieur
carreau le nouveau directeur commercial
d'air france en remettant un festive car
on la première carte de réduction la
première des jeunes france car nous
avons estimé que vous représentiez ces
jeunes pour son aspect de jeunesse
courageuse et sportives et nous avons le
plaisir de vous remettre cette carte du
club des jeunes ainsi que le billet
correspondant des compliments de la
compagnie nous souhaitons que vous ayez
le maximum du succès pendant l'année qui
vient les félicitations
nous avons pris cette mesure pour nous
sommes persuadés que les jeunes ont
envie de voyager de la seule question
qui les arrêtent est une question de
prix c'est pour ça que nous avons lancé
cette affaire qui est une opération
maintenant mondiale c'est la première
fois que dans en europe par exemple on
arrive à avoir des tarifs de jeunes
spéciaux uniquement pour les jeunes et
quels sont les vols concernés par cette
réduction se sont tous les vols
européens
sur l'ensemble des lignes européennes
jusqu'à la turquie de même que les vols
européens entre
l'europe et l'afrique du nord est ce que
les jeunes pourront bénéficier cette
réduction sur le réseau intérieur
légèreté nous et vous pourrez y avoir
également ces réductions je l'espère
plus tard sur d'autres secteurs et sur
le plan pratique un jeune qui veut
bénéficier ses traditions que doit-il
ferme sur le plan pratique il suffit de
s'adresser à une agence air france ou à
une agence de voyage ou vous demanderez
votre billet aller-retour pour tels des
citations vous montrerez votre carte
d'identité on stoppe grassement là une
carte du club des jeunes d'air france et
vous aurez votre réduction de 25% sur le
parcours que vous aurez non